optimal at this altitude I can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking and oil is your personal
question now it is
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by audible which has the
largest selection of audiobooks on the
planet I have used audible for many
years and I have several audio books to
recommend right off the bat if you're
looking for a new one ready player one
by Ernest Cline you may have heard of it
the town of Seneca by Seneca if you want
to hear my favorite collection of
letters of all time as well as the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman which is a
fiction book I use to reintroduce
nonfiction purists to the beauty and
truth and enjoyment of fiction graveyard
book it is incredible and I like the
version that Neil reads himself but the
entire ensemble cast is also fun audible
members get a credit every month good
for any audiobook you the store
regardless of price and unused credits
roll over to the next month so if you
didn't like your audiobook no problem
you can exchange it no questions asked
plus your books are yours to keep with
audible you can go back and relist in
any time even if you cancel your
membership and for some books again
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman I've
listened many many times you may even
just start over as soon as you finish it
the first time
audible also helps you to listen to more
books by letting you switch seamlessly
between devices picking up exactly where
you left off whether it's on your phone
through your car from a tablet or at
home on Amazon echo whatever you can get
through tons of books hands and eyes
free while doing almost anything so that
is part of the beauty of audio it is a
secondary activity when you're walking
the dog cooking whatever it might be
audible content includes an unmatched
selection of audio books original audio
shows news comedy and much more from
leading audio book publishers
broadcasters entertainers magazine and
newspaper publishers and business
information providers maybe that's what
I am a business information provider and
right now audible is offering listeners
of this podcast a free audio book with a
30-day trial memberships check it out go
to audible.com forward slash tim and
browse the unmatched selection of audio
programs download a title free and start
listening it is super simple go to
audible.com forward slash tim or
texts Tim - 500 500 on your telephone to
get started today check it out
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books fresh books has become the go-to
cloud accounting software for literally
millions of small business owners who
found a faster more efficient and much
less stressful way to deal with their
numbers and ultimately this helps you to
focus on what you are best at it is used
by many of the fastest growing startups
I've invested in or advised and it's
equally used by many of the best
freelancers I work with on a daily or
weekly basis it is one of the easiest
ways to send invoices get paid track
your time and track your clients if
you're self-employed and managing
business sometimes means wrestling with
spreadsheets crumpled receipts and other
scattered pieces fresh books can really
help fresh books allows you to do many
many different things very easily
preparing and sending a polished branded
invoice takes about 30 seconds you can
set yourself up to receive online
payments from your clients in about two
clicks which on average will get you
paid twice as fast there new proposals
feature means you can include a project
summary and timeline as part of your
estimate there are many many other
things tracking your time the quick
proposals that I mentioned formatting
free super easy late payment reminders
you don't have to chase people automatic
expenses sharing files and messages with
your clients award-winning customer
service they are extremely responsive
the interface is super intuitive and
there's almost no learning curve so in
short it's easy it saves you time and
right now fresh books is offering an
unrestricted 30-day free trial for all
of my listeners to claim yours check it
out go to FreshBooks dot-com forward
slash Tim and enter Tim Ferriss in the
how did you hear about a section and
that is funky spell t IM f e RR is s so
again go to fresh books comm forward
slash tim and enter tim ferriss and how
did you hear about us section check it
out
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show or it is my job to
interview and deconstruct world-class
performers of all different types to
tease out the lessons habits routines
and much more that you can apply in your
own lives and my guest today really blew
me away
I implore you I beg you to listen to
this entire conversation I was so
impressed from start to finish
his name is George raveling and I do owe
a debt of gratitude to Ryan holiday for
making this introduction George raveling
on twitter facebook and instagram at
george raveling ra ve l ing coach george
raveling comm is an 80 year old living
legend and Nikes former director of
international basketball coach RAV as
he's often called was the first
african-american basketball coach in the
pack 8 pac-12 and is often referred to
as the human google for reasons that
become abundantly clear in this
interview he has held head coaching jobs
at Washington State the University of
Iowa and USC following a prolific
basketball coaching career he joined
Nike at the request of Phil Knight where
he played an integral role in signing a
reluctant not many people know that
story Michael Jordan he's also been
inducted in the nice Smith Memorial
Basketball Hall of Fame as well as the
College Basketball Hall of Fame we cover
a lot in this wide-ranging conversation
in Austin Texas we cover how he was
given the original copy of dr. Martin
Luther King Junior's I have a dream
speech which was not the name by the way
originally how his practice team ended
up beating the 1984 US Olympic dream
team in basketball what the story of
getting Michael Jordan to sign is Nike
why coach Rav has been nicknamed the
human Google his voracious reading habit
and how he picks books and takes notes
we had a huge nerd out over how to take
notes in books the wisdom of his
grandmother and other mentors and much
much much more
I really walked out of this conversation
floating on there
and reflecting on and thinking about so
much of what he shared he's an
incredibly impressive human being I hope
you enjoy this even half as much as I
did which would mean it's probably going
to be one of your favorite episodes that
I've done so without further ado please
enjoy the ever impressive Jorge raffling
coach welcome to the show thank you very
much it's a pleasure to be part of your
world I have been looking forward to
this conversation ever since our mutual
friend Ryan holiday gave me a teaser of
your life story and when I started doing
homework and prep I started thinking to
myself I should try to get coach to
spend the next two days with me I should
cancel my flights because we're gonna
barely scratch the surface in the time
that we have today and I struggled with
where to start because I have pages and
pages of notes of my own and you also
sent me I will give you credit where
credit is due the the absolute best
exploratory bullet to any guest out of
300 plus gases sent me and we're gonna
start somewhere that I think may
surprise people and that is the I have a
dream speech
so could you can you tell us about your
relationship with that please well it's
it's one of those stories about being in
the right place at the right time it was
a Thursday night in Claymont Delaware
and I was having dinner at my best
friend's home and his doctors are very
his dad was a very prominent dentist in
in Wilmington and so in the background
as we ate then in those days everyone
ate dinner as a family and so in the
background the television was on and the
news was commentary was about the
forthcoming march on Washington and so
my friend was named Warren Wilson his
dad was dr. Woodrow Wilson and so he
asked the question of us
are you boys gonna go to the march on
Washington and we said no and he's asked
us why not we gave him some a youthful
excuse that we didn't have any money or
way to get there and so he said well I
have a feeling this is going to be a
historic event it could be the largest
gathering of black people in the history
of America in one place and so he said
and I think the two of you should be
there he says so what I'm gonna do he
had two cars he said I'm gonna give you
one of the cars and money and you guys
should attend and so the next day we we
took off for Washington DC on Friday and
at that time there was one main
thoroughfare into Washington DC was
Route one and so when you come in you
come in off in New York Avenue and so
there were a lot of what we call motels
in those days along there and we found
one that was suitable to our economics
and we got a room and so we decided that
we would go down to the monument grounds
just to get a feel for the best way to
get there and what it was going to look
like and so as we were walking around we
encountered a gentleman and he asked us
I'm 64 and 164 so he asked us if we were
coming to the March the next day and we
said absolutely and so he said would you
want a volunteer and so we said for what
and he said to be security guards so we
said sure we'll volunteer and he said
well we're expecting twice the
attendance that the papers are
predicting and so we have to add
additional security so he said we'll
meet you down there the next morning at
8:15 and so we got there early that we
woke up we were all excited so we get
down there and we find him and he said
well you guys are really early and so he
looks at how tall we are and he says
well we've decided we're going to put
extra security up on the podium and so
we're going to sign you guys to the
podium and and so they they had these
little white hats which we maybe like a
sailor hat but they're cardboard they to
wear for identification so we were
stationed at the podium where all the
speakers were gonna
so to give you some backdrop on it the
all the speakers and they start at nine
o'clock in the morning if I remember
correctly John Lewis was the first
speaker and then there was a series of
speakers throughout the day concluding
with Martin Luther King as the last
speaker some people would suggest that
it was he was the keynote speaker but he
really wasn't they put King last because
they knew he would hold the crowd so
part of the stipulation was each speaker
had to submit in writing his speech that
he was going to give and that could not
exceed five minutes there was a hard and
fast rule on this and what was
interesting about it was that James
Baldwin submitted his speech and he and
they felt it was to exclamatory they
they were worried about getting the
crowd too excited and maybe having a
demonstration and and Baldwin's speech
was over five minutes and so they
wouldn't accept it so Baldwin refused to
speak but he was originally to be one of
the speakers so as the day goes on it's
a hot and humid day and and as you look
out from the Lincoln Memorial you look
out to what they call a reflecting pool
all the way back to the Washington
Monument and as the longer the day when
the hotter it became the more energized
people were and so we finally get to
that point the the end of the day and
Martin Luther King comes on to speak and
so as history will show King speaks I
speaking from prepared notes and he gets
about a one-paragraph left and as he
speak in the crowd is just mesmerized
but he he has captured every single
ounce of attention in each human being
and and he had a cadence about the way
spoke that he would say how long it had
these what I call drumbeats and he had a
way of raising and lowering
voice to manipulate you as a listener
and and so he's just about toward the
end of this the last going to the last
paragraph and you hear a voice and today
with technology could certainly do it
but the female voice from seated behind
the podium says tell him about the dream
Martin tell him about the dream well the
voice was that of Mahalia Jackson who
most people would say as the greatest
gospel black gospel singer of all time
maybe the greatest gospel singer of all
time she had worked on previous
demonstrations and gatherings with
Martin Luther King so she had heard
Martin Luther King tell the I have a
dream part in Selma and in Detroit and
so if you look at the original speech it
was not part of the original speech and
second he's the only speaker who
exceeded five minutes and so at that
point the crowd is just mesmerized by
him and so and he ad-libs in the I have
a dream speech and then and then at the
conclusion he goes back and closes out
with the prepared closing so when it's
over we were told to form a V around the
podium and helped to usher him out so it
just as he finishes the most frequently
asked question is is why did you ask him
for the speech I have no idea was just
impulse so I say to dr. King as he's
following his speech I said dr. King
could I have that copy of his speech and
and just as he's folding and he
instinctively hands it to me and and
then a rabbi who's doing the benediction
says dr. King that's a great speech that
I'm so inspired
so his attention shifted away for me to
the rabbi and so we when a bride
finished a benediction
I actually CBS went through the archives
of Johnson & Johnson Avenue magazine and
they found the picture of me standing
right beside him at the podium so I I
actually have a picture that verifies
that I was there and CBS was able to
find some footage where he was folding
this that's the speech and they can see
him handing it but but didn't show my
hand in it and so at any rate when it's
over they go over to the White House and
as they walk into the Oval Office
President Kennedy says dr. King I loved
your I have a dream speech well so the
media took that and ran with it because
if you see the original speech the
speech had no title and so little did I
know at that time that this was going to
take on the historic significance that
it actually took 50 years for it to
really find its rightful place in
history
it makes me mindful of something that
hurt Malcolm X say one time that history
is best situated to record all man's
deeds so my interpretation of that is
history and historians ultimately will
put things in their rightful place and
so it took 50 years well so I had no
idea at that point when I had the speech
that it that it was going to become a
valuable historic document so when I got
back home I put it inside of a book that
I had from that president Harry Truman
gave me so my senior year at Villanova I
played nice West's all-star game and it
was in Kansas City and one of the things
that they did is they took us out to
Independence Missouri to meet President
Truman so and when we went out to meet
him his office at his home was a replica
of the Oval Office and so as we walked
in each of us noticed there was two huge
tables to the right would book stacked
up on him well at the end after
President Truman had talked with it with
all the team and the coaching staff and
trainers he on the way out he gave each
of us a two-volume book of
that he wrote on his presidency and so
in the book it and which I still have
both of them now both books say to
George raveling from harry s truman best
wishes and it has the date so I put the
speech inside of one of those for a
couple reasons I would remember where it
was in - I knew I'd never throw those
books away because how many people can
say they have an autographed book by the
President of the United States
personally to you so it stayed there for
years and years and I never thought
about it I actually my wife didn't even
know I had it because that and so I go
to the University of Iowa as head
basketball coach and of course I'm the
first black coach during first in the
Big Ten and so this there's much to do
about this at that time all the local
newspapers big newspapers had a Sunday
magazine section on and so the cover
story on the Cedar Rapids Gazette paper
was gonna end this magazine session was
going to be about me taking the
University of Iowa head basketball
coaching job so as he was asking
questions he what I call a throwaway
question he said coach were ever
involved in the civil rights movement
and I said well can and he says what
does that mean I said well I went I
attended the march on Washington I was a
security guard and and I was able to
secure the speech and at that point if
I've ever seen a person just physically
decompose as I said I mean he was he
just he he didn't know he was so much
more I couldn't figure out why I was so
excited and so he says oh my god of you
who haven't he said where is it I said I
only been there about six weeks so I
hadn't unpacked all the boxes down in
the basement so I said it's in a box
down in the basement he said can we go
look for it and so we go down and not
figure out what your box it wasn't I
pulled it out and he was literally
shaking and and so he said oh my god
he said can I call my editor can we take
a picture of this and so I said sure so
little that I that was the first public
notice that I had this speech so is so
the story kind of now
starts to split between raveling being
the head basketball coach and raveling
having this speech and so from that
point on it took it took on a little
different significance but it's still
time had not placed it in its rightful
place and so over the years it became
more and literally one of the miracles
tim is that for 50 years i had this and
nothing no flood the house doesn't catch
on fire somebody's doesn't steal the
book whatever and if you saw the actual
speech now have it in a vault in LA the
for the speech to survive this this long
and and and and the quality of the paper
it's typewritten you can see little
little typos in there and so forth and I
had a friend of mine who graduated with
me from Villanova who was with the FBI
and and so one time we were talking
about it he said well if you ever get in
a situation where someone doubts that it
that you really have the speech or that
it was good he said we can lift the
fingerprints off of there he said your
fingerprints are on there it's those
kings so it was an interesting
circumstance that what became the focal
part of the speech was something that he
never really intended to use and only
through the motivation of mihály Jackson
that he ad-libbed the the I have a dream
piece in so as the years went on it took
on a unique value and so at one point my
Turner Sports doesn't documentary on it
and so like my wife goes to work people
are talking all I didn't know about your
husband having the speech so my wife
comes home one evening she says hey we
gotta have a talk I said okay she says
the speech has got to get out of his
house right away she said you travel too
much somebody's gonna break in the house
and and and I might get killed over the
speech so she said you got to get it out
we put it into the ball and as naturally
would happen
various people tried to buy it from me
but I I never felt that I had total
ownership of it I kind of felt like I
was the guardian of something historic
and I became so sensitive about it that
I stopped I would on Black History Month
I did many invitations to come bring the
speech talk about it but I was so
self-conscious that I stopped doing him
because I never want anybody to think
that was profiting off of this and I
never entertained entity offers just to
sell it and when I was growing up as a
little boy in DC my grandma used to
always say that money's the root of all
evil don't build your life around money
and so it wasn't you know I wasn't rich
but I wasn't poor and I wasn't desperate
to make money or headlines on it the
headlines of crude because of people's
curiosity about having it but I look
back on it now and it was a classic
example of being in the right place at
the right time and which has happened so
much in my life getting good adult
advice if dr. Wilson doesn't say you two
need to go and I'll provide the
opportunity for you then I would have
missed out on a piece of history that is
put an indelible mark on my life what an
incredible story
what an incredible experience you think
about the how the stars aligned had to
happen it and from that point on I
learned a good lesson that you don't
have to have a relationship with a
person for them to become your your
mentor and so in those days I I don't
even know if I knew the connotation
mentor but I I looked at King more as
someone as a teacher someone I could
learn from so as we fast forward and I'm
now
working at Nike and in my office I had
had this picture in my office and it was
a headshot of Martin Luther King James
Baldwin and Malcolm X and so when people
would come into my office they would
look at the the things on the wall and
they would always be drawn to that that
portrait and so they what was
interesting most people I would say 99%
of people could could not tell you all
three of them a lot of people would get
King some would get James Baldwin very
few Malcolm X but it was rare to anyone
got all three of them so they would ask
me why I had it up there and I said
they're my mentors they're my
inspiration that they're the people that
I lives I look to when I'm trying to
figure out something complex and so
while I didn't have a day-to-day
relationship with dr. King I had a
mental day-to-day relationship month to
month week to week year to year because
there was so much that I wanted to learn
from him and one thing while it's in my
mind I'd like to share with you and I
don't know if the vast majority of
people that follow King nudists I just
found out this past weekend reading a
book review in the New York Times a book
review section that when dr. King was in
the seminary at Crozier which is in
Chester Pennsylvania that's where he
took his practice to become a preacher
that doc
they had a basketball team and dr. King
was on the team and so that delighted me
to no end discover that he that he he
played basketball during the time and
the person who wrote the book actually
found in the archives a box score from
one of their games and unfortunately
they got whacks 124 to 41 so but I was
so pleased to find out that there was an
athletic side to him and I don't know
and all I I've read about King over the
years I never known that he participated
in athletics always there was a
immediate joy that to find out that a
and particularly they play basketball
and when you said you had a relationship
with say dr. King in the sense that you
viewed him as a mentor or a role model
and you revisited that would you find
yourself in specific situations and ask
yourself you know what would doctor can
do or how did how did that fit in your
life from a mentorship standpoint was it
just putting yourself in their shoes to
make hard decisions or how did you think
I think one thing that that became
quickly apparent to me was that the
value and of words and and and and the
spoken word is such a powerful tool
perhaps maybe more powerful than the
atom bomb in many ways the fact that
that he had a vision that the whole I
have a dream so all great leaders I
believe share a vision and then they
then they have a journey and so he
talked about the division the journey
the completion of the dream and and and
the conquering of of injustice but to me
King was was so many things he was a
preacher he was a messenger a visionary
it was a precursor a leader he he was a
man for all seasons in all reasons and
in many ways and so what many times I
reflect back on something that he he
said that when I when I'm in a tough
spot and I think about giving up he said
to yourself that's what kind of
sacrifice is this going to be and one
thing I remember dr. King saying is if a
man or woman hasn't found something in
life that they're willing to die for
then perhaps they're not fit to live and
so he lived out that that that a reality
that he became so deeply immersed in in
this mission that he ultimately had to
give as his life for it
and I watched a number of documentaries
over the years and under sit-ins and
during that the depth of segregation and
one was the night before that they were
in a sit at the lunch counters and and
the the person who was leading the the
demonstration as they were planning out
it strategically at the end he said to
them he said I want everybody in the
room to look around at each other and
shake hands because tomorrow night when
we have this meeting some of you're not
going to be here and I thought to myself
oh my god would I have the courage of
commitment to know that if I were in
part of this demonstration tomorrow
night I might get I have to put my life
on the line I might not be back if I'm
sitting in that room I have to say to
myself are you willing to sacrifice your
life for this cause and and to me a lot
of the untold stories about segregation
and and and Indian justice is that black
people have faced most of our lives is
those people who died so that we can
enjoy the things that we enjoy in
society today and and so to me whenever
I have any questions about the depth of
commitment I I go back and I say to
myself do you feel so strong about this
that you'd be willing to give your life
what do you feel this strong about it
that you would be willing to risk
getting fired and and over the years
especially when I was at Nike sometimes
I had a depth of belief and conviction
that what I was suggesting was right and
I was willing to fight right down to the
end and if it meant I got fired then I
got fired but I never allowed the
position or to threaten me to be less
than what I should be as a person you
mentioned your grandmother in passing
and she seems to have been a very
important figure
in your life how did that come to be the
case well my grandma was basically if I
can borrow a religious concept my
grandmother was the Pope her word was
infallible what and what was interesting
my grandma was a product of a Blackfoot
Indian tribe and on both sides our
family we really are descendants of
American Indian tribes and which I find
interesting sometime because of that we
now I've gone through these these
connotations when I was when I was a
firstborn which you'll find interesting
I was born in the segregated Hospital in
Washington DC Garfield Hospital and
there are four floors for whites and one
for for black so I was so I came into
the world in a segregated world but so
as I was growing up when I was nine my
dad died and when I was 13 my mom had a
nervous breakdown
and she was institutionalized the rest
of her life in those days the the
economy was was in poor shape so you got
rations from the government you got like
flour sugar so milk so forth and so I
come home one day and my mom standing at
the sink and she's got the water running
and she's pouring this big bag of sugar
into the sink and just letting the sugar
go down and so I I grabbed it and turned
it off and I and I said mom what's going
on you and she just she was incoherent
so anyway my mom ended up being
institutionalized so now here's George
at 13 years old and Norma's wealth and
and so what'd he do with George he has
no he has he has no parental supervision
dad's dead mom's in a mental institution
and she spent most of the rest of her
life there and so my grandma worked for
this white family in Georgetown
and so she was sharing with the lady of
the house this dilemma and so she and
she was saying I don't know I don't know
what what I'm gonna do but I have to do
something for him and so the lady said
her daughter was was a head of Catholic
Charities in DC and she would mention it
to her maybe her daughter could do
something so lo and behold the daughter
decides that what she's gonna help and
so she found the school a boarding
school for me a Catholic boarding school
in Pennsylvania was called st. Michael's
School for Boys it was and so you she
was able to get me into the school there
you stayed there year around as a
resident and so I went off to st.
Michael's and the structure where
priests were were renting the
institution and the teaching and and the
service part were done all by nuns and
so over the course of the time I was
there I did everything from bale hay to
pick apples a clean chicken coops to
work in the kitchen to scrub the floors
in the chapel to make to make beds you
had to do a chore to help offset your
presence there and so the classes were
very strict and rigorous that the
classes were small so we got a lot of
individual attention and it was it was
just a stroke of a miracle that my
grandma was able to get me into this
situation and she my grandma never
graduated from high school in fact no
one in my family my mom and dad finished
high school but she knew that there had
to be a better way for me and she did
everything that she could to help me
grow as a person
I remember one one time Tim my grandma
took myself and my brother out and and
she said
we're gonna go outside I want to teach
you some some manners and lessons and so
my my grandma takes about brother and I
out on the street and she says and I'm
gonna start to teach you how to treat
women women are to be respected and so
she says when you walk down the street
you always walk on the outside the woman
always walks on the inside when you when
you when you get to the corner you make
sure you check the traffic in both ways
before and then you walk as more as a
guard if the woman's getting in the car
you always open the door for them first
if you sit down the table for the meal
though you hold the chair and help them
and so long before feminists or a
movement because was even thought of my
grandmother was teaching us social
graces yes sir no sir I go on a flight
now and and it's just part of my DNA
when people say some stewardesses I
might say yes ma'am no no ma'am yes sir
no sir
and I'm 80 years old and I still do that
but so invariably what will happen on
the flight is either during the flight
or at the end
the stewardess will say to me it can I
ask you a question now say yes I know
it's coming and they'll say are you are
you from the military and I say well I
was in the military but but no I'm not
in the military now and and they said
well are you from the south and I said
no and so I said why do you ask and they
say well because you're so polite no one
says yes ma'am and knows and I have a
lot of people now who find it
uncomfortable if I say yes sir at 80
years old and they're younger than me
but it's just the way I was born my
grandma was was huge on manners and if
we went somewhere and and there were
adults there in those days if you were a
child kids were to be seen and not heard
and so if there was a conversation going
on again with the adults you just listen
and but if if someone asked me a
question and I didn't say yes ma'am and
no ma'am
when
got home my grandma would say i heard
mr. jenkins asked you that and you just
said yeah and she said bend over and she
would she whipped me and so and my
greatest quote for my grandma was she
told me one time she said there's more
horses asses in the world than there are
horses no that's all that's been my
favorite grandma quote she's a good
teacher and a good enforcer he sounds
like well were there any other mentors
during that or teachers or people who
had a strong impact on you over that
stay in that Catholic school yeah there
was a nun who took a liking to me named
sister dolor she she lived to be 87 but
she for some reason she saw something in
me I never saw him myself and and she
would always say positive things to me
at the time I didn't realize the value
of him but she'd always say to me George
you can be special or or if I wasn't
working up to my potential in whatever
area it was she would say and that's not
being special and you were you're on
earth to be special and Knight to me
I've never had anybody look at me and
and and and make me think I could be
anything other than an average but she
constantly preached that to me and she
would watch the basketball games and and
and after she would come up or the next
day in class she would say well you know
in the third quarter you you you you
really you really were loafing out there
I was embarrassed but she always found a
way to to write a paper and she'd read
it and she say this is really good but
this is not your best stuff you can do
better than so she always kind of
created this contest of having me
compete and compete against myself it
was never competing against the other
students as always me competing against
myself so she she taught me that the
power
of positive of a positive attitude she
would never allow me to think negatively
and then the other person was my college
or was my high school coach he taught me
so many lessons about length at our
school that there were four sports
boxing baseball basketball and football
and so one of the things that you
learned if you wanted to get off campus
um you participate in sports and so I
actually participated in every one and
the one that probably gets zero
attention because a lot of people just
don't know what's boxing I actually box
Golden Glove really years yeah I know
you
you're Chinese foot boxing so you can
probably identify with that but I
wouldn't want to deal with you and so I
actually somewhere in when my high
school scrapbooks I have a picture of me
and a ring and those that you were the
headgear had a big lad big gloves and so
I fought and in my weight class though
it's at that time I wish I was under 200
pounds now but uh so I I actually won my
senior I won a Golden Glove event and so
and then I played a baseball I played
first base and pitched and then football
I played in all except the last year and
then we didn't have a good quarterback
so my coach put me at quarterback but I
was believe me that my talents word I
wouldn't even gotten a walk-on offer but
I was the quarterback and then what
happened was basketball between my 8th
grade year in ninth grade year I grew
four inches so I went from six foot to
64 in one year and so obviously the
height advantage proved beneficial to me
early on in basketball and so over the
course of the four years I got better
and better and when I look back on it
now a lot of it was sister delorca
encouraging me kept tell me all you're
getting better off
and you can so she kept be motivated all
the time so my senior year I ended up
being the second leading scorer in the
state of Pennsylvania and so at this
point let's just step back real quick so
at the end of my junior year I'm waiting
I'm gonna waiting for to take the
Greyhound bus back to DC for I got a
week vacation back in DC so I'm sitting
there waiting for the bus to come by and
Tim I can remember it was like yesterday
I thought to myself God if I can just
graduate and become a pilot in the Air
Force I'll have it made I had no idea
anything about basketball was gonna take
me and get me a scholarship so the
following year I end up the second
leading scorer in the state and so we're
playing at st. Rose in Carbondale and
after the game when I come out of locker
room legitimate comes up to me and he
says hi my name is Jack Ramsay I'm the
coach at at st. Joe College and he hands
me a card of course Jack Ramsey is in
the Basketball Hall of Fame great coach
and so he said that I like the way you
play we'd like to offer you a
scholarship and I said yes sir every
time you'd say something I just say yes
sir because I didn't know what else to
say and so on the school bus ride back
to the school my coach says who's that
man you were talking to outside the
locker room and I said he was a coach
and I hand them to the card and so my
coaches or what did he tell you and I
said he said that he wanted to offer me
a scholarship and so I said coach what's
the scholarship because I had no idea
what that you could that they would pay
for your education in return you
participated in basketball so then by
over the course of the remainder season
I had an offer from Michigan State
Villanova and again gettysburger a bunch
of those schools but I add getting Zabur
because their coach did the best job of
recruiting me he'd write me hand written
let and letters four and five pages on
what it was going to mean to go
Gettysburg and so 4d drive up two games
he was so persistent but at the end of
the day the reality was just as far as
the nuns and the priests were concerned
it would it would have been heresy to go
to a state institution I was going to a
Catholic school so then he basically
came down to st. Joe's and Villanova and
I went down for the visit and Villanova
and while I was there they gave me
admissions exam you have PSAT and a CT
then and so I took the admissions exam
the first day I was there and once again
amazing insight by sister Dolores she
when she found out I was going to get
scholarships offers she started to make
me stay after school everyday and work
on on the entrance exams so so I was
prepared in the na and so the Sunday
before we left to drive back up to Hoban
Heights the coach-house severance
offered me a scholarship and and they
wanted a decision why we were there so
basically like my high school coach made
the decision he thought that that's
where I should go and and little did I
know that that basketball is going to be
this transformative force in my life
that was going to take me someplace I
never thought that I could go to never
in my life and I don't mean this in a
mean-spirited way did anyone in my
family ever say to me George when you
grow up you I want you to go to college
it was there was no reason for them to
think that at that time it was it it
wasn't it wasn't even a dream or thought
because nobody had received that type of
education and go back to my grandma so I
call my grandma and I tell her what's
going on and that I'm gonna get this
scholarship and so I tell her well how
does it work I said okay so if if I
agree to play on the basketball team for
the four years they'll they'll pay for
my education so my column a sudden
there's other silence on the phone
and I said grandma are you still there
and she said yes I said why you so quiet
she says oh I just feel like a failure I
said what do you mean and she said I
thought I raised you better than that
and I said well grandma what did I do
wrong and she said stupid don't white
people gonna gonna give you a free
education to play basketball you how can
you go how could you be so stupid to
believe she could not comprehend that
that because of the the racial situation
that someone would pay for your
education and all you had to do was play
basketball and she she just it took her
over a year before she fully was able to
even trust that this was that when I
finally got on campus at Villanova and
and went to the first class then then
she she kind of started to be a lot more
trustful of the process but it it was a
I look back on it now and it just shows
you the depth and the of a stain of
racism and how things are are implanted
in your mind that you just can't they're
kind comprehensible so on that on that
note when I was doing homework I read
somewhere that you have a collection of
racist mementos yes in your house could
you i beyond that i don't know the
details but that just stuck in my mind
and cuz that's something i think that a
lot of people would actively avoid so
why do you have this collection well
first of all i you know no one's ever
asked me that question but i spent i
probably have over a hundred thousand
dollars worth of black collectibles for
about eight or nine years that it became
an obsession with me and so I would go
to antique shows and and and and go to
stores and hunt down all black
memorabilia I have things that date back
before I actually have a first edition
of Uncle Tom's Cabin so I started to
collect books the figure rings
in postcards postcards that was I start
out with figure rings and so I I friend
of mine told me about a an antique store
that was closing and and the gentleman
had a huge collection of black
collectibles
and so it was in San Pedro so I went
down and and I paid him $35,000 for the
collectibles he had I wore 100 pieces
and part of the deal was that he had to
mark them and write a little card so I
would understand the historic
significance of postcards Tim I have him
back before you had which this might
surprise you that originally that you
didn't have to put a stamp on on the
postcard to send it out to mail so I
have I have them back in the earliest
one I have is 1891 Wow but what was
interesting about the black postcards
was they always made blacks they
pictured them in a derogatory term one
of the more frequent ones you see is a
black person with a eaten watermelon wit
with a smile on his face but they were
all derogatory now here's what's further
interesting on weave now you put stamps
on them so I I was able to read the
messages on some of them and and and so
the one that I remember the most is the
ladies right into one of her girlfriends
and we'll just make up the name she says
Helen we have a [ __ ] that works at our
house that smiles just like him and so
in those days to use the word [ __ ] was
commonplace and you just I don't know to
ever learn to accept it but it was it
was something that was said commonplace
so I started to build this historic
collection of memorabilia so that I
could have a legacy for my children and
their children and I
I have them on display at my home to
remind me of how of where we were and
where we are today and and trials and
tribulations that we've gone through so
I easily have postcards I probably have
over 300 of the postcards and I probably
have about 500 of the figurines I was
just thinkin because I have some I have
some of the original and jemima of
flower part of pax and that I it once I
got going it was amazing that things
that I was able to to collect and so I
had so many of them that I couldn't put
them all on display so I have probably
3/4 of them are boxed up in storage but
and then the others are around my house
do you collect anything else or have you
collected anything else books and
Friends and my library at home I have
well over 2500 books and probably have
another 6 or 700 that are that are in
storage because it just ran out of space
but I just continued to buy books to
read them I have as you probably
research I have an unusual way of going
about reading books but and and and and
friends I don't have a strategy or
anything for friends that most times
people when I meet them are not who they
ended up being whether it was Phil
Knight Bob Knight John Thompson Sonny
Booker I could tell you tons of people
when I met him they were not who they
ended up being but for some reason we
were able to build an authentic and
sustainable relationship and I've always
looked upon relationships as a privilege
that you had and you at the end of the
day at the core of all relationships in
my mind is trust and respect and so both
of those have to be earned
and so over the years I've met people
and unintentionally we've stayed in
touch and there's been this level of
trust that that's allowed the the the
relationship to endure but it's
something it's a lot like marriage you
have to work at it you have to to
understand that there's a balance in
relationships and with me I'm the number
one thing that I asked myself
continually is what can I do for you and
your good friend Ryan holiday and I had
dinner last night and one of the very
last things I said to him I said Ryan is
there anything I can be doing for you in
the next thirty days I've always had
this theory that if you help enough
people get what they want you'll always
get what you want and so I've never
tried to enter a relationship based on
selfish motives that if I noticed person
I'm gonna get these benefits III so I
try to find out what do we have in
common as people what is it that we can
share how can I help this person no
matter how famous they are how
successful they are
everyone has certain needs even if
they're just psychological needs or or
we all need truth tellers in our life
and so and building relationships I try
to make sure that I surround myself with
people who want to see me become better
and can help me become better that I can
learn from them and and that I can
contribute to their lives and so most of
the friendships I have in life they they
all started by by mistake you wanted a
young men that that's here today that
has taught me almost all I know about
technology I spoke at a clinic and in
Orlando and I so a friend of mine Kevin
Eastman was running the clinic and I
said to him I said who's gonna who's
gonna put my presentation up on this
green in that you have a IT guy and he
said yes and so so I said well introduce
him to me because I won't put my
presentation up I want to walk to the
back of the room and make sure it's
clear and so forth so so I meant
Alex Lavoisier and and during the time I
was there we just hit it off and so when
he I'm pretty sure he was taking me back
to the airport and I asked him if he
would be interested in doing a website
for me and he said yes and so that's how
it started and has turned into a
lifelong friendship and you know I think
that was the start of me recognizing
that I needed to be around more young
people and so I I don't associate and I
mean it's bad to say this but I don't
hang out with many people my own age
most of the people that I associate with
are younger people because I think
they're the future they're smart they're
naive enough that they'll tell you the
truth and and they're not afraid to tell
you if they think you're wrong and when
I hang around people my own age that
tends to always revert back to the past
and and so and I don't want to talk
about coaching at Washington state of
being the first black this or the first
black that what I want to do is is is
figure out at 80 years old what is it
that I don't know but need to know and
how is is going to help me stay relevant
in this ever-changing world and so I've
tended to spend most of my time with
younger people who inspire me who who I
can and have a partnership with that's
the other thing about relationships I
think relationships at their most
authentic stage it's a partnership it's
it it's we share we share common vision
common goals common objectives common
strategy common execution plan it's it's
a we mentality it's not a me went out
mentality and it's a win win mentality
it's not I win you lose
or you
I win it's not about that we would we
were in this thing together and win the
boat together we're gonna row in the
same direction and we're gonna get the
boat ashore
you mentioned books and I want to make
sure we give reading at least a few
minutes because you are known as a
voracious reader the human Google one
nickname and you've read probably I'm
sure thousands of books at this point
you were very kind when we first got
here
we're recording this right now you said
I learned from the the wise men it's
always a good thing to bear gifts or
something along those lines and you gave
me several books you've also gifted many
many different books how did this love
affair with books start and could you
tell us about how you read books because
as you alluded to earlier you have a
particular way of reading books well as
I look back on it now Tim and with a
point of reference to so many times as
we speak is always going to be my
grandma well my grandma told me one time
and she still wouldn't she'd be in the
kitchen cooking she'd tell me stories
and one time my grandma told me she said
George you know back in the days of
slavery the plantation owners used to to
put their money in books and hide them
up on this put him up on the bookshelves
because their banking system wasn't as
sophisticated as it is today and so I
said well grandma why did they do that
and she said because they they didn't
have to worry about the slave stealing
the money because the slaves would never
take the books off the shelf because
they couldn't read and so from that I
began to understand that as long as
someone can control your mind they can
control who you are in your body and so
I decided that I was never going to
allow myself to be in a position where
someone can could control my mind and
control my body because of my lack of
information and knowledge and and so I
decided that
I was gonna try to read and learn as
much as I possibly could on a continual
basis because I believe that people will
have a greater respect for you if if
they respect you in intellectually and
I've often felt in life if if I had the
choice between tim liking me or tim
respected me i'd far more hope that that
you respect me then like me and i
figured the byproduct of you respected
me will be that you'll learn to like me
so i don't work at trying to get people
to like me so I've been on this mission
for for a reading for years and years
and years and it's become an obsession
now with me I I I don't go anywhere
without a book and and and a notebook
it's like if I'm if I'm in line if I go
to the doctor's office I take a book
with me if I'm in the I have a new
system now if I go to a book store and
I'm in Barnes & Noble and the line has
got eight or nine people and rather than
staying there for ten minutes waiting I
start I'll start reading the book right
there in line and start underlining
things and so I have all these quirks
that I've acquired over the years with
reading books first of all I divide the
book into messages I don't think I don't
spend any time now trying to read a
whole book cuz there there's probably in
most books there's probably maybe eight
to ten chapters that are really powerful
and influential and and the others I
skim through so I never start a book
from the front and and and go to the
back I just go I'll open the index and
I'll find what I believe is an
interesting chapter and I start there
and that's actually how I purchase a
book when I'm in the bookstore I have
this
routine that I go through that and and
if it passes I buy the book and if it
does and I don't buy the book and what's
your routine so so if I let's say I'm
gonna envision this one so our offices
is an El Segundo which is outside of Los
Angeles and and so I go to Barnes &
Noble there one thing I found out that
because there's so many corporate
offices within a two mile radius that
they tend to house really excellent
business books so I'll go in and soon as
I go and I go look at the books that are
on reduction sale to see if there's some
something there that might be a good buy
then I go to renew read new releases
nonfiction and by the way i go to i go
to a book store four to five days out of
the week i'm constantly going in and i
just call it search and discovery so
i'll go to new releases in a nonfiction
I'll look through the books there's
usually 20 books on the table I'd say
eight out of ten times I'm gonna find a
book that that I had never heard of
before and so I'll pick the book up I go
to the back I read about the author then
I go to the front part and I read the
promos down the side and then the next
thing I do is I go to the the chapters
and and I'll find the chapter and I'll
open it up and I'll see the writers
style I look at the style is this
someone that says book filled with a lot
of statistics or stories because I know
what I'm looking for the books that have
have had the most impact are the ones
that make me change the way I think or
act or behave and those are the books
that ultimately end up being the best
for me so I'll go through the book and
then once I find this one chapter I
start to read some of it and now and I
can tell if this is going to be me or
not and at that point I'll purchase the
book but I just don't go
and by a book based on on the top ten
not that there's anything wrong with
that it's just that I've had better
success and then so now here at 80 years
old two of my favorite authors are Ryan
holiday and Walter Isaacson they've both
taken me on interesting intellectual
journeys the first book I read by Walter
Isaacson was Steve Jobs and I was so
blown away I had underlined about 3/4 of
the book I was quoting writing down
quotes and and as you know the Steve
Jobs book couldn't be anything you want
it to be it can be a thesis on
leadership
it was just utterly fascinating I loved
Walter Isaacson's writing style so when
I finished a book I looked I went back I
said Tim I liked the way he writes so I
go back and I look to see what else he
had written and so I didn't I see he's
on a book on Benjamin Franklin he's done
a book on on Einstein so at the end
subsequently Kissinger and others so I I
go to the book store and I buy the
Benjamin Franklin book and I am blown
away and a little sad because I feel
like god damn I went through all this
education no one ever taught me in it is
the father and make the kite and so
before that I think if you to ask me who
was the most important American of all
time I think I would have probably
tended to say Abraham Lincoln but after
I read Isis's book on Benjamin Franklin
there was it was I would now feel I mean
if you know the lottery system that the
banking schools streets the guy did he
did so many unbelievable things and then
from there I went to Einstein and
anybody who can write a book on Einstein
that an idiot like me can understand the
the
physics and and it was it was absolutely
it was a miracle
so in the book Tim I read that Einstein
was very active in what they would
capture those times as the Negro
movement and it says that he wrote a
book on Einstein in the Negro movement
well I had never heard of this so I
immediately stop reading and go google
Einstein on a Negro problem and lo and
behold it comes up so I chased a book
down and so what I find that a lot of
times in reading books in is in in in in
in in your book tools of the Titan I'm
reading and I and I see this you
mentioned in there about masterminds and
I had never heard a mastermind so I
Circle it and I write Google behind it
so I go back and I go online now and I
and I find out wow so I'm thinking to
myself oh my god how do you know I never
knew about this so how do i how do I
become part of it so I sent some
information to Ryan holiday about about
this mastermind so he gets back to me
says oh yeah I'm surprised you didn't
know about that he says you you want to
go I'll get you in so the next thing I
know I get this invite to go to
masterminds in Carmel Valley and and my
80 years on earth that was the greatest
collection of intellects that I've ever
been around him I'm in my life I was so
intimidated and what was marvelous that
was when I knew I was on the right path
because every I'm 80 years old that
makes all this person there's probably
49 you're all young energetic people and
I was I was readily admit I was so
intimidated I didn't think I was think
to myself God how am I gonna fit in and
every night I went to bed with the worst
headaches that I ever had because I was
like I couldn't process all this stuff I
felt about his second day I've already
filled up a notebook of notes
and it was one of those life-changing
experiences so you you helped me grow as
a person just by what you mentioned and
tools of the Titan well thank you for
reading it first of all and this is I'm
I'm sure that with all my notes here
today I'm gonna have to figure out a way
to have another conversation with you
for sure so I hope hopefully I won't
blow it between now and the end of the
interview but books that you've read the
most yourself or gifted to other people
the most are there any books that come
to mind well you know being 80 years old
it's a long span of reading the books
that I've given out the most rarely do I
I mean I go to meet anyone and I don't I
can't tell you the last time I met
someone and I didn't bring them a book
it's just become a habit now to bring it
to give them a book in most cases I give
them two or three books but the books
that I've given away the most lately are
Ryan's two books obstacles obstacles and
and ego is the enemy and 12 rules for
life by Jordan Peterson who I actually
that this is one where I happen to go
into Barnes and Noble the date of book
arrives and I go through it and it gets
passed as my test and so I get back to
the to the hotel and I started reading
the book and before I know it's 2 a.m.
in the morning then and I'm still I'm
the guy's got me hooked already and so I
started telling people all you got to
get this book and no one's ever heard
this guy although and Canada I
understand he's quite controversial he's
a professor at the University of Toronto
so then about three weeks go by and all
of a sudden as an explosion it's now
number two on the bestsellers and so
forth so I would say I probably have
given away somewhere between 20 and
and 30 copies of that to friends i sus
I'll get a note from someone every now
and then saying hey tell me a good book
to read that that's the one I recommend
the most I give Tim's I mean Ryan's
books away a lot one thing that I like
about Ryan's book it's it's easier to
carry because it's smaller yeah like I
can get a little bag and that can put 12
of them in there yeah mine up mine are
not as user friendly from caring
perspective no that's the one thing I
found what your two books is it's that I
take them on as a personal challenge I
said if he spent this much time with
this many pages I am NOT going to allow
that the length of the book to
intimidate me I'm gonna see this as an
opportunity and so you what what I did
with tools of the Titan was that I call
that my china book so it's it's 13 hours
of shanghai or 13 hours of Hong Kong 13
coming back that's 26 hours man
so I could I think I can knock knock
that sucker out I just and some books
you just have to find the right
environment in which to read them
totally so I'm gonna actually just pause
for a minute we'll keep the recording
going I'm gonna go grab the books that
you brought for me so I'd love to talk
about those I'll be right back okay so
here we have five books and I'll just
read off the titles quickly and then I'd
love to hear you explain your reasons
for choosing a few of these perhaps so
the first is life is so good
George Dawson and Richard Glavine the
next is the true believer subtitle
thoughts on the nature of mass movements
by Eric Hoffer next we have blue
highways by William least heat moon
that's quite a name then we have
whiplash how to survive our faster
future joy IDO and Jeff Hal
actually no joy I have not read this
book though so she put it on they enjoy
Nanaki sticker design the truth
Hector McDonald I would love to hear you
and explain why you like or why you
chose perhaps a few of these
III think well my first goal was as I
said to you when I first entered the
room is that what I learned from the
three wise men was they always came
bearing gifts and so I felt that that I
wanted to share something with you as
you were of values as you were sharing
something with me of value and allow me
to be on your program so I thought long
and hard about the types of books that a
Princeton graduate would find
interesting and so I went back through
and I and I I know the first one his
life is so good is about about a black
young man who was a slave and that 98
years old he decides that he's going to
teach himself to write Wow and then he
subsequently goes back and gets his GED
and it's a fascinating story about that
he never allowed his environment to to
imprison him he it took him a while to
realize that that he had the
capabilities to still read but what was
more important was that he wanted to do
it and so he he taught himself to read
he ended up going back to school and now
and one of the things in here was uh
they have a couple letters that young
kids who read the book and and so here's
a cute when it says dear mr. Dawson I'm
in second grade I live in Wisconsin I'm
glad that your brain still works happy
10th anniversary and then one other one
that says I'm happy that you can read
now I'm glad you like school I do too
I'm in the fourth grade your friend Alex
just and this is to me as one of the
true classics of all time this is the
true believer by Eric Hoffer or Hoffa
was a longshoreman in San Francisco
his self-educated and in this book is
about about fanatics and how the people
become so engrossed in mass movements of
a lot of the backdrop for his rationale
has to do with Hitler's rise to power in
Germany and and this distorted remember
I'm pretty sure the book came out in
1951 he wrote this and so it's every bit
as contemporary as in fact if there was
one of these books that I would say that
you someone's to pick up and read right
now I would say it's so applicable even
though it was written in 51 on on is
this the true believer by Eric Hoffer I
don't think you can get it in hardback
now but it's a marvelous book blue
highways is it was one that I read twice
and William lease heat moon was a
professor at a and English at the
University of Missouri and he arrived at
a point where he was totally bored at
being the professor and he makes a
unique decision to abandon his career
sell everything he has yet he has a
credit card he sells everything he has
and he decides that he's going to he's
going to travel the blue highways of
life and he's going to go all around the
America and all he's going to do is go
into small towns off of blue highways
and and take up residence there for a
day to a week and just talk to the local
inhabitants and going to restaurants and
learn other people's stories and inner
challenges and successes and so that the
blue highway the connotation and I
noticed because I thought map reading
when I was in the Army is the the the
the the on a map the the the blue
highways are secondary therapy and and
as the the major highways that are drawn
in red and so he decided that I don't
want to travel or
America on the main highways of life
because the real stories are off the
blue highways and and it's just an
incredible story of his journey and it
gives you a look at America from a
perspective that you you wouldn't
normally and what you find out even in
these little towns around America there
there's not a whole lot of difference
people they have their anxiety they have
their joys they have their visions but
one thing I noticed was that people in
the smaller towns tend to lead a much
simpler life and and and their values
are a lot more sustainable what I mean
by that they're that they have fixed
values that they've grown up with from a
child and they've never compromises a
great book I I once again I spend a bit
of time trying to figure out which one's
I thought you would would like the the
actual next one is I bought at the
University of Penn bookstore about five
months ago I never go to Philadelphia
and don't go to the pin book store and
and they have an incredible collection
of books and so at that time I was
thinking to myself you know you need to
change the subject matter a little bit
the dominant conversation is America's
is the future the future get to the
future first what's the future going to
be look like and so I started to realize
you know you need to understand more
about what it the future and what it is
and what the potential are so I'm as I'm
going through going to the bookstore I
decide only books I'm gonna buy our
books that to talk about the future so I
ended up buying about six books and so I
came across this as as the good Lord
helped me discover this book and it's
called whiplash how to survive our
faster future and it's written by two
professors at MIT and the book is is is
incredible and as you can see how I
ideas Lloyd looks evil
lot of underlines do you mind if I take
a quick look at no no I just wanna I'm a
bit of an note-taking fanatic so always
fascinated to see how people take notes
so you have underlines you have things
that are circled and I see Google here
then you have something that is circled
and looks like it has spines around it
it's like almost like a cactus
so is that yeah what do you reserve that
for the ones which circle are I'm always
looking for way new ways to explain
things and to teach so those are words
that I'll go back and I'll transfer into
one of my journals because I'm looking
for new ways to explain things sometimes
a person will be mentioned and and so
I'll circle that I'll write those down
so every day I take about a half an hour
on and Google at Google people's names
like Google as I said with masterminds
and then I I I'll have where you see the
markings on the side of a paragraph that
means when I go back that I want to
reread that in its entirety and it's
really you know these this market right
here so but it looks like just for
people who are listening to this it's
it's basically a bunch of horizontal
lines stacked in the margin from the
beginning of say this paragraph to the
bottom of the paragraph so that's
something that you will reread yes
and make comments like on this paragraph
I wrote unbelievable this was a quote
that I wanted to put in my journal on
quotes and and so this was a person that
was mentioned that I wanna i want i
wanted google's a lot of times what will
happen tim i go back and i google a
person and and and i'll then immediately
i go to see if they have a twitter
account and that they do then I then I
signed up for their Twitter account and
so to me the handheld device has become
my own personal library and my source of
information but where I've discovered a
growing problem is
there's this huge proliferation of
information today we're overwhelmed with
information and so what I find out is
that it for me I have to have I have to
segment the information so I have this
little formula information equals
knowledge knowledge equals wisdom wisdom
N equals growth growth growth allows me
to share so so I take the the the
information and I segment and then to
magazine reading blogs articles and
books and what I found out is that I was
devoting an inordinate amount of time to
blogs articles and magazines and
newspapers and and and it was it was
compromising my book reading so what I
had to do was to start to plan out my
week and so I'll have I'll have a day
where I say blogs magazines and
newspapers in then I'll have a day where
is a book day so on that day I'm not
doing anything but reading reading my
books the other thing I have to do is
try to figure out other ways to get book
reading in so if I if I hop on a flight
from LA to to Austin I I put four books
in and in my book bag that I carry on
the plane and I I read four books at a
time I have a lot of crazy things I do
this is what you're reading now this is
one of them yes so just for people
wondering how wide-ranging this is the
mind is the title it's projections and
multiple facets by Yogi Bhajan
PhD master of Kundalini Yoga with guru
Chara and s Khalsa PhD amazing so so
what I do is if I get bored when I'm
reading I'll just switch to another book
or
and no until I get one that really
captures my attention so when I get on
the plane I'm gonna I usually start off
I read The Wall Street in New York Times
in the local paper and then by the
second half I'll go to my books and so I
like I said I just have all these crazy
things so for example I've trained
myself to understand that the the blank
pages I've made all the blank pages in a
book a valuable because I take every
blank page and I write and I write notes
in there so I don't have to switch to my
notebook real it's more handy so as you
can see under a lot of blank pages and
you're running on other everything yeah
right and as I go I skip around and Wow
so hold on this spread you have three
different highlighters you have I
suppose pink yellow and green and you
have some red emphasis at the top of
that particular page well what what I
what I do is it helps redirect my
attention to what's important if if I'm
if you saw a speech that I gave for
example I was a graduation speaker a
couple years ago at Villanova and if you
saw the speech that it's it's it's just
a maze of colors and I my brain is
trained that the colors will will
redirect my attention and so if it's all
pink then in many ways it really wasn't
any sense to underline it I mean to
color it so I tend to go back once I
read this a book I go back now and I'll
reread the book and and and and and and
and go with the underlining again and
sometimes if it's really powerful enough
I just do it right then so on the the
key phrases or words that you circle so
my system is I put pH in the margin next
to it which stands for phrase and then
on the very beginning of the book I
create an index of phrases so I'll have
pH and then I'll put in the the book
numbers and similarly you do these
multiple passes so and I'll go through a
book and I'll underline or highlight and
then I'll go through it a second time in
the margin I'll put t2 and a circle
around it just for Tim to like second
pass for things I find really
interesting then if I read it a third
time I'll go through and I'll do t3 and
so I can I can not only see what was
interesting me interesting to me at
different times but also sometimes I'll
get so excited reading a book I don't
know if you do this but I'll highlight
so much of like okay well I might as
well have not highlighted anything
because I highlighted everything and
then the second time around I'll be a
little bit more precise maybe and so
that I can go back and I have my own
table of contents which it looks like is
similar to what you do yeah what I've
found out is in reading books now is
when I go back on the second passage of
the book reading it I find some pages
that we're where I didn't have anything
underlined and and so just my
inquisitive self I'll go back and and
read that page and they'll be three or
four things like that that I wanna
underline are one to ponder on and and I
can't understand wow how did I miss this
so the second reading for me is is
revealing because I always find
something that I missed that maybe my
brain just was what was functioning too
fast or I was being distracted and so
I've learned that the second reading is
is vitally important and so then the
last thing I would do is I would end up
transferring these two journals and I
actually have book notes back to 1972 is
when I started to keep him in three-ring
binders and what I would do is when I
was done with a book I would just give
the book to my ad those days were
secretary so I'd give it to my secretary
and she would type out everything that I
had underlined in the book and then she
create a cover page for it and so I I
have
three-ring binders I probably have 12 or
15 from Washington State and I'd
probably have I only stayed at Iowa for
years but I'd say I probably have about
eight from Iowa and and probably maybe
15 or 20 from USC so I actually have
them that my I saved my notes over the
years and one thing that I that they've
been a great source of not only learning
and reflection but I can like find
information that I can utilize in in
speeches and it's it's interesting also
when you look back in the I think people
50 years ago placed a greater importance
on on writing skills and the word usages
and it was it was an art form now and
and and and how people would go about
explaining themselves is but most of the
books I read I they're very few of them
that I don't come away and feel that I'm
a better person one of the things I like
to ask myself at the close of every day
is what did I do to make myself a better
person than I was yesterday what did I
learn today and and so for most talk
that I do I say that every day is
composed of 86,400 seconds of
opportunities and how shameful is it for
me at the close of my day to say that I
didn't do anything today to make myself
a better person and that was yesterday
and that's shame on me because I had
86,400 seconds of opportunities that do
something even if it's no more than that
then a thank you are random smile a pat
on the back
think about this Tim there are a lot of
people in in this country who go through
24 hours and never have anyone say
anything to them positive you might be
the only person that day who said
something to that person that was
positive or I know
we're in a different culture now and and
I always think I'm running a little risk
but if I'm in a restaurant or somewhere
and I in and the person's waiting on me
and he or she has a great smile I in
verbal II say hey you have a great smile
I sometimes I feel a little uneasy when
I say to a female because I don't want
you know someone might think of trying
to come on to him but at the same time
I'm willing to take that risk so earlier
when we were leaving breakfasted that as
we were leaving the two waitresses said
thanks for coming and they had a big
smile on their face so I said to both of
them both the two of you have a great
smile well to me I like practicing
random acts of kindness because so much
today we're cruel and unintentionally
cruel but we don't think what how
valuable the little things are the
thank-yous the smiles that taking time
to listen I had a situation I still
grapple with this when people ask stop
you on the street and asked for money so
we were we were having lunch yesterday
and a lady came up and she asked for
Africa spare some money she wanted to
get something to eat or drink so I gave
her five dollars and I said now I hope
you used to five dollars on what you
said you you're gonna do so she points
in as a little grocery store a few
historic doors down she comes back shows
me to drink and the three dollars change
and so so where was a win for both of us
but as I grappled with this thing about
do I give him some money and adore do I
not but and in this case I mean I really
felt good that that I was able to do
something for her and she did something
for me because she made me feel good
that that I could trust
what she really did is help for to fly
my mind that I should probably be giving
more and instead of less well you've
given a lot in a lot of ways in many
years of your life and and certainly one
capacity is that of coach and we were or
educator or teacher and we could spend
days and hopefully well hopefully we'll
get to know each other even better and
spend more time together but for now I
thought we might jump forward at least
from your childhood stories to the
Olympics 1984 and there are many
different angles we could take to to get
into this but I suppose where I want to
start there's so many different things
that I want to touch on but since we
were talking about communicating and
phrasing and words could you could you
share the motivational quote that you
came up with at that time and I think
it's each one of us has a relative who
gave his life for this country the least
we can do is give 40 minutes of
ourselves yes that was that's actually a
Bob Knight quote and and it was a
motivating force because when you stop
and think about it very seldom in our
lifetime does our country ever come to
us and say we need you it's all it's
always the exact opposite that we that
we're looking for something from the
government but I felt that this was a
unique opportunity that the country was
basically saying to the team and the
coaches that we need you and we need you
to bring back a gold medal force and so
this this was a unique opportunity for
us to serve our country and I can
remember vividly in the months leading
up to the 84
because in Los Angeles I would envision
that we were gonna win the gold medal
and we were gonna be standing there and
and and hear the national anthem play
and to be at attention in one look at
the American flag I know that we're in a
different era now in a different time
but the reality was this is how I felt
and so I've I grew up in an era where
where my grandma taught America right or
wrong America whatever the problems are
we'll work them out but but at the end
of the day we're an American and so I
envision what was it going to be like
when we stood there and received a gold
medal and and heard a national anthem
played and you had the satisfaction is
saying to yourself mission accomplished
and it was it was one of the most unique
experiences I've ever had in my life to
be in a position where you could
represent your country and and you could
feel have a good feeling about it I I'm
sure there'll be a lot of people who'll
question why I felt that way but that's
the truth of the matter and I was
chatting with Ryan or texting with Ryan
last night actually had dinner with you
and he was he was peppering me with
suggested topics which of course we have
an overabundance of but one of one of
the bullets here in the notes in front
of me is that refers to you leading the
practice team to beating the dream team
can you elaborate on this place what
happened was for the first time in the
history of the Olympics the United
States decided not to use college
players anymore but to use professional
players and so that year the Olympics
were in Barcelona and Chuck Daly was
that the head coach of the US team and
of course you had I think the only
player
on that dream team that's not in the
best while all the fame right now is
Christian Laettner was he was the only
college player on the roster and of
course you had Magic Bird Barkley Jordan
you name it was and so Chuck and I had
been lifelong friends back from when he
was an assistant at Duke and I was an
assistant at Villanova and he was a
Pennsylvanian grew up in Bucks itani so
we had a long-standing authentic
relationship so Chuck decided that they
wanted to put together a group of
college players that which would
scrimmage the dream team twice a day in
practice and so he suggested that I be
the coach and so CM Newton who was head
of USA basketball at the time called me
and asked if I would would would be the
coach of the team and I said I'd love to
do it so they picked the players and
Bobby Hurley and Chris Webber and a
bunch of guys we only had eight players
and Roy Williams and I coached the team
together and so the first night that we
had the scrimmage
I think the NBA guys basically looked at
us as a this is just a scrimmage and
college guys and so they didn't really
take it as serious as we did a college
guys they were four we were all fired up
this is a great opportunity so we
scrimmaged for 37 minutes and and we
actually beat them in the scrimmage and
so the word got out and they were livid
so one thing that happened I picked one
of my managers from USC to be a manager
for our team and so when the when the
practicing that Larry Bird came up to me
and he said coach Keith said can you do
me a favor I said sure what he says can
you leave a van and a driver here or
have somebody come back and pick me up
and so I said I'll leave one of the
managers would have van so and Larry
hadn't shot the ball that well in the
scrimmage so he stayed and shot for an
hour and 15 minutes straight and so I
told him
ah Dennis Johnson who was the manager I
said when you get back let me know your
back and so when he came to my room I
said how'd it go he said coach he said
it's unbelievable he said he just
continually shot he said I only took one
water break and he said he was drenched
and and a head to toe and he looked at
me and he said coach if a Larry Bird is
doing this what should the average guy
be doing and and it was just a great
experience I saw the next not the time
we scrimmaged they were they were fired
up
so we I'm embarrassed to say this we
didn't score a field goal for the first
nine minutes I mean they were on us like
white on rice and they were they said
you guys think you're hot ass you know
we're gonna show you and Jordan was
leading the pack and so they they were
determined okay you guys think you're
good we're going to show you what what
good is so I want to talk about coaching
a team and I think the way I'd like to
get into this is by asking if you could
maybe mention just one coach that you
have been impressed by alive or dead
past a present doesn't matter and what
impressed you about them oh I would say
to coaches who actually have to say
three three coaches who have had an
immense impact on me as a person as a
coach my life would be Bob Knight John
Thompson and left teachers l left
yourself I was his assistant at the
University of Maryland he was the one
who taught me whom who fueled my passion
for reading he was the one who taught
taught me that that you don't just read
the sports section he actually got me
into a system that I still use when I go
to a newspaper now the last section at a
newspaper I read his sports
and that's something that started back
with him he also told me the importance
of reading the editorial page every day
and in he and then the other thing was
he he wanted us to be the best-dressed
staff in the ACC so I picked up a lot of
habits from lefty that I have to this
day John Thompson I grew up in the same
neighborhood in Washington DC he had
he's had so much influence on the way I
think the way I act what I believe the
one thing I learned what John is when
you're around John you talk to listen
ratios the listen ratio should be 90%
and the talk should be 10 because if
it's any other way you you've lost a
great opportunity to learn and to be
taught because he's he's a he was John
as a maverick thinker and he was a
maverick thinker before the connotation
even existed and the other person Bob
Knight I just had an absolutely amazing
impact on that when I was at a summer
league game as an assistant coach at
Villanova and half time I go down to
look at the scoreboard and the guy taps
me on the back and and I turned and he
says hi my name's Bob night assistant at
West coach West Point and I say hi
George Romney assistant at Villanova and
from that moment on we had a lifelong
friendship and that's how I ended up
being the assistant coach on the 84
Olympic team but maybe Bob's greatest
gift to me was that he saw something to
end me that I never saw in myself and he
was relentless to make to make sure that
I achieved that he he said to me George
if we're gonna survive in this
profession we have to become an expert
in some phase of the game and you need
to make yourself an expert in some phase
of the game Bob's was defense and so he
said to me he said I know you speak a
lot of clinics on rebound and that's
your niche you got to make yourself the
foremost authority on the globe on
rebounding and he stayed after me on the
phone he called me one night he said hey
I looked it up in the Library of
Congress there's no book in the Library
of Congress on rebounding so you've got
a unique opportunity and so I still
didn't believe that I could actually
write a book and so he bobbed just
stayed after me so finally he said write
it write an outline and send it to me
and then of course we didn't have a
technology who did it so I wrote an
outline and sent it to him so little did
I know he was setting me up the voice to
walk me through this and so the the
Marla's story is I end up writing a book
called one night work was rebounders
workshop and in the what and the other
ones called war on the boards that that
was the thesis and the manuscript for
the art of rebounding and I I probably
sold a hundred thousand copies over the
years of the book but without Bob
staying on me and and being relentless
and never accepting no he helped me find
something inside of me that I would have
never in my life ever thought I would
have written a book and or even had the
talent to do but he saw something to me
that other people didn't see in me and
that's been a lot of of the relevance
for this magical carpet ride I've had in
life people seeing something in me that
I didn't see in myself my grandma seeing
something that means sister Dolores
saying something to me my high school
coach seen something in me my cup my my
college coach our servants he said
something Tim that I'll never ever
forget one time he was talking to us and
he said the first sign of intelligence
is to admit that you don't know
something and and Here I am eight years
old and and I still remember him telling
me this that and and so I've learned so
much everyone that including yourself
touched my life in a in a in a
productive way if I don't read tools to
the Titan I don't know about master mind
if I don't learn about mastermind I
killed myself in 20 different
relationships I I learned things about
people that I didn't know so it's just
been a blessed journey that you meet
people who are willing to help you
continue to grow especially at 80 years
oh well now if you think Tim from that
sixty years old that the thought process
in America was you retire you get a gold
watch you live happily ever after
but between 60 and 80 it might be the
most productive years of my life I've
grown so much I've I was 63 years old
and I get appointed a global director of
sports marketing at Nike at 63 years old
so how does the II defy the odds X
basketball coach blatt no business
background and you're running you're
running a fortune 500 category and and I
can remember many times thinking that
all of four years I spent at Villanova I
was an econ major an economics major and
at that time they didn't call it this
business would call the school of
Commerce and finance so I graduated with
a degree in economics and I used to
think god this is a waste of time I
learned all this I'm never going to use
it and little did I know that at 63
years old all this was going to come
back to fruition and it was going to be
necessary and so it did pay off and as I
understand it the the job offer or at
least you're beginning with Nike came
through what seemed like a prank call
from Hell night at least that's what
I've read you got
started long before that when I went
went to work full time for them I get
this call and then we'll go back to the
to the origin I get a call one night and
I answered a phone and and the voice
says this is Philip Knight and that's
basically how Phil always addresses it
to this day if he calls he's gonna say
this is Philip Knight and so I from a
momentarily at the oddest somebody put
me on so then I said is it really that
it's full night I said what's going on
and he said I just called to see if
you'd be interested in coming to work
for Nike full time and so we talked it
through and I said well what do you want
me to do and he said I want you to come
and at that time like he had this camp
called the all-american camp and he said
I want you to upgrade it but I want I
want to figure out how we can reach
younger kids and so I still have
somewhere and storage the original
presentation that I made to him to start
a grassroots program at that time there
was no such thing as a grassroots
program and and so that was the start of
me working full-time but I actually
started at Nike and and in 1978 the Nike
decides they're gonna get college
coaches to endorse their product and
they fly 11 of us to Las Vegas and Jerry
Tarkanian was one Jimmy Valvano and so
forth and so John Slusher senior and
Phil came and made the presentation to
us and essentially they would give you a
compensation and all the product for you
and your team and this is in 78 and so I
was sitting beside Bill Foster who was
coaching at Clemson at the time and so
the the the the second day we had to
make a decision and so part of it was
they give you the compensation a
compensation was five thousand in cash
or 5,000 in stock that the impediment
really wasn't as it turned out was if he
took the stock he couldn't catch the
stock for five years and at that time
the stock was about six bucks and so
Bill Foster
leans over to me and he says George take
the stock take the stock I'll explain to
you later he said all these other idiots
are going to take the cash and so the
five year thing ended up being a
disciplinary factor because even if you
wanted to you couldn't cash it so so
then when the the five years passed bill
called me about six months before the
due date and he said you listen to me
again don't cache the stock don't cache
the stock just let it roll over he got
this far without he can get the rest of
the way so anyway by time I finally sold
the stock it was up to 46 bucks so I
went and and and it is splitting so but
to go back I so that year in 78 Nike
sends Bill Foster myself and Eddie
Sutton to to China for a month to do
clinics and so we went to to Peking
Shanghai and Guangzhou so at that time
Beijing did not exist subsequently
Beijing was peaking was replaced with
Beijing but at that time it was called
Peking and so we we went in and did
these clinics in China and at that time
it was highly communistic everybody
dressed the same the women dressed with
white blouse and olive green slacks and
and the men had these little Nehru
jackets at olive green and they had a
cap with the red star on it they could
speak no English and so one day we're in
Tiananmen Square and Bill Foster his
wife had a Polaroid camera and she was
taking pictures and so she took a
picture of a group of Chinese people
standing together conversating and so
when then when we developed she showed
it to him and they were that was like
Milady's well been for the moon day was
so we couldn't tell what they were
saying but they were there was so
excited pointing and then more people
came and they they had no idea how this
was transpiring so here's here's an
interesting story Tim so Chinese
gentleman steps out of the crowd and he
comes up to me any
picks my hand up and he rubs my hand
looks at his fingers and so it was
apparent he had never seen a black
person before in his life and he thought
it was paint Wow and so he was rubbing
to see if the paint because he couldn't
figure out he'd never seen a black
person before and it's a story that's
left an indelible mark on my my stay but
that was maybe that one of the great
trips of of all time I tell you one
other quick story we're doing a clinic
in in Shanghai and an interpreter comes
up to me at the end of my lecture and he
says coach he says this coach would like
to borrow your rebounding book and he'll
bring it back in the morning so I
thought he just wanted taken all me read
it so the next morning comes back sure
enough it gives me the book and he's got
25 copies of it you started working
full-time at Nike it's at age 63 all
right well no I actually that took the
global sports marketing job at 63 I
actually had put in about eight years in
developing this grassroots program at
Nike and then subsequently I got this
opportunity to be the global director
and you mentioned familiar name to a lot
of people Michael Jordan earlier from
the dream team and I've seen a
photograph of you as a very young
Michael Jordan sovereign that you're the
one who actually convinced Michael
Jordan to sign with Nike or certainly
were one of the driving factors there
could you share that story I don't know
if I would go that far but I was a
cotton doing so early and when we at the
Olympic Trials Sonny Vaccaro who was
then heading up Nike basketball and Phil
had came to me and they said hey can you
see if you can get Michael to visit with
us and so we were still training in
Bloomington so I I brought the subject
up with Michael what happened was I
don't know exactly how this happened
but Vern Fleming who was on a team from
Georgia
Patrick Ewing myself and Michael we were
inseparable the whole Olympic experience
we went everywhere together we and we
were like the four amigos we go to
McDonald's we go to the movies a
shopping mall wherever we did it was
always the four of us and and so I
developed a really unique relationship
with Michael so from time to time I
would bring it up to him about the Nike
thing without being overbearing and in
the very beginning he said cochise's
yeah I have no interest in like I'm an
adidas guy I'm gonna go to adidas I
don't even like their product and so
every now and then I would bring it up
and he would say coach I'm telling you
man it's a waste of time I'm going to be
an adidas guy so now we get through the
we're at the Olympics and we get through
pool play and we have a day off and so
Sonny Vaccaro calls and he says hey can
you bring Michael get him to come over
and meet meet me at Tony Roma's in Santa
Monica so I bring it up to Michael and I
think just out of frustration to get rid
of me he just said okay I'll go so we're
going over in the car and that he said
coaches I'm only doing this for you he
said that it's a waste of time whatever
Nike offers me I'm gonna take it to
adidas and if adidas matches it that's
it that's who I want to be so to the
Fast ForWord he ends up him and his mom
and dad and David Falk come up to Nike
for a visit and the meeting is is
successful but it didn't move the needle
because Michael was still convinced that
he should go with Under Armour but part
of the Nike Adidas I mean I'm sorry
adidas and so part of the deal was at
that time there was no such thing as a
signature shoe and so David Falk came up
with this idea of air Jordan and so and
Nike would make a signature shoe that
would be marketed under this logo of Air
Jordan
and so when the meeting goes well we
think we got a shot and so true ders
word Michael took the deal back or David
took the deal back to adidas and adidas
passed on it because of the signature
shoe thing because they didn't feel
there was any market for it and and and
they still made him an offer but but
they wouldn't go on the signature
shooting and and I if I remember
correctly Michael was getting five cents
a royalty on this shoe so at any rate
Michael ended up accepting the offer
from Nike and as they say on television
the Restless history but here we are
today and and Jordan Moran is is a
business of its own so so like there's
Nike Inc and then you have these subsets
early converse Jordan brands so Jordan
Brand is the second biggest seller of
basketball shoes in the world basketball
shoes other than Nike Inc and they sell
more basketball shoes and Under Armour
or or adidas and so here you go back to
84 and here today he sits at the head of
one of the most profitable sports
Footwear companies in in the world and
what's interesting which historians will
put in a rightful place one day is Nike
was the first fortune 500 company to
take a black male and make them the face
at her company and then you I'm sure
you're familiar with the Spike Lee ads
and all those things like that and so
there was a huge risk in some ways but
one time I mentioned the Michael about
Nike taking at risk and so he quickly
came back to me he says Nike took a risk
hey I took a risk to see you you've
spent so much time teaching and guiding
and cultivating players and people who
work for you and the people around you
I had read and please feel free to to
correct this but that you've said the
most important conversation is the one
you have with yourself yeah so could you
could you elaborate on that please
because III I think that self talk is
and I'm not sure that's what you're
referring to it's so so terribly
important so I'd love to hear you just
elaborate on that the older I've gotten
the more I've come to the conclusion
that the the that the conversation that
you have everyday with yourself as you
characterize it self talk is so vital
it's far more important than the
conversations you have with those around
you and the best part about the
conversation with yourself is you're in
total control of that conversation you
can craft the conversation any way you
want to and so I try to have at least
90% of the conversations that I have
with myself which I have two or three
times a day that it's a positive
self-talk if I start to linger on to
something negative then what I'll do is
I'll immediately deal with it and
discount it for example since I'm
Catholic I'll make this confession so
this morning when I got up your
reputation is so impeccable that I was I
was uh you know I got put five I'm
really nervous I'm thinking to myself
God what if I if I do a bad job I'll be
so embarrassed and so the minute I
started thinking that I said nope that's
not it get fired up man you're gonna do
it and I'm so I mean I mean I'm in the
bathroom and I'm doing this motivational
talk for myself to eradicate any doubt
that I have and and and and I keep
saying to myself you got to go in there
you got to give me a best shot duck you
can do it huh so I'm getting myself
fired up for it and this is out loud
yeah I mean because I really spare
as much time is probably at least oh I
wouldn't say probably once a day I'll
find an hour it just goes someplace and
sit by myself and all I do is take a
notebook and and this put it in a pin in
front of me not just sit there and think
whatever comes into my mind and then
then I start to fixate on those things
and or I'll write down notes as a result
of something that I think or are right
out of strategy for example the way I
govern my day Tim is is I get up in the
morning and I put my two feet beside the
bed and I say to myself okay George you
only have two choices today these are
the only two choices that you have and
you got to make one and the two choices
are to be happy or to be very happy and
there's no other choice and so then I
start to plant a plan out my day and I'm
all in so I I have these these points of
focus energy a time an energy management
time management environmental management
productivity and to me productivity is a
byproduct of the other three so how do I
manage my my energy every day so that I
can that can be at maximum efficiency so
one of the things I try to do is
declutter my mind I won't do any more
than four things a day and it it reverts
back to something one of the presidents
at Nike Charlie Denson said one time in
a leadership meeting he said let me ask
you guys this
will we be better off doing 25 things
good or will we be better off doing six
things great and so to me to make
simplify my day I will not do more than
four things I try to limit the meetings
to two and if it's to one of them is
usually a breakfast meeting when I go
into the office I have I have a total
commitment once I get into the office to
be totally focused on on business
matters try to be as disciplined as I
can not to get on the telephone and and
also to meet with with the two people
that work with me we meet every single
day and we talk as a team because I want
us to function as a team I want each
person's opinion to be valued if one
person happens to be 50 years younger
than me and so what their DARAB their
opinion is valuable to me I respect
everyone's knowledge and I think to
myself they know something that I don't
know and so I wanted to evaluate our
opinion so we meet every day as a staff
we talk about things and and it helps me
grow and and it keeps my day simplified
I try to clean I try to once a week have
a personal audit I go back through the
week and I audit my week and and and and
make course corrections along the way so
that's when I really get into the
self-talk part is having these little
mental audits that my life is just not
going on and on and on I try to evaluate
am I making progress what am i doing
that's good what am i doing that's
that's not working and then make those
course corrections and at 80 years old I
try to hold myself to the most severe
standards and and I just despised the
idea of retirement and I think that it's
the was the biggest force that's ever
been predicated on us is this idea of
retirement because the first thing that
happens you retire you physically and
then you retire mentally and then you
just taken up residence in in society
and I don't ever want to be a resident
of society I want to be a contributor to
society we've you seem like you're just
getting warmed up
what are you most excited about these
days and working on well what I get most
excited about is just waiting when
you're 80 years old you damn sure better
be excited that you wake up the next
morning and you have a growth
opportunity I'm still trying to
understand like most of us what what the
future is gonna be like and how can I
get to the future first and what's the
future going to be like but I read a lot
of books and talk to a lot of people but
I don't know if anybody can really tell
you what the world's gonna be like five
years from now not ten years from now
but five years from now we're in a
society where it behooves all of us to
be comfortable with with change and to
be comfortable with being uncomfortable
if you could metaphorically speaking put
anything on a billboard not not
commercial but a message a quote a word
a question somebody else's quote could
be anything to get out to millions or
billions of people what what type of
message your word or quote or anything
might might you put on that billboard I
would say if I could put up a billboard
then and the message to people that the
quote would be if it is to be it's up to
me because at the end of the day each of
us have an individual responsibility to
ourselves in to to our society to figure
out ways to be positive difference
makers and it all starts in life
I'm fondest reminding myself that
nobody's gonna roll your boat free but
you you got to get in and you gotta row
your boat to the other side of the lake
and so I would remind people as I said
if it is to be it's up to me and that's
something that I had on my office door I
had a big sign at Washington State I had
it on my office
or it's something that I've tried to
make an indelible mark on my brain that
it's up to me if changes about that the
best the most authentic change takes
place in within yourself and so be and
often times in life timbers you know the
most important person you ever get
delete is yourself and if you can't lead
yourself how are you gonna lead other
people and so I I would like to
challenge people to start to look within
before they look out is to look within
and and and what are the what are the
things that I can do to be a positive
change mic maker in my life and in the
life of others when we talk about being
a positive change maker the thought
process is this is about trying to
change society but when I hear people
always say to something that has changed
the world well if you want to do
something that's going to change the
world you change first
and that's gonna that's and if everybody
started to feel that way we'd have this
huge movement of change that would be
authentic hear hear
I'm getting all fired up and get at that
coach I want to be respectful of your
time so I think we're gonna wrap up
shortly here but is there anything else
you'd like to share any other parting
words certainly people can find you at
george raveling on twitter instagram
facebook linkedin website coach george
raveling comm i encourage everybody to
check it out but is there is there
anything else that you'd like to
recommend just coming off the hook
because all my youthful advisors said
coach make sure you tell people how to
how to stay in touch with you but it's
it's all technology and has helped me be
create a platform of sharing to try to
share one thing my grandma said to me
one time she was correcting me and and i
was a little smart aleck e and so she
looked at me in a stern way and she said
she said boy let me tell you something I
know where the potholes are and
and maybe if you listen to me I can help
you avoid stepping into them so at 80
years old like I think of my grandma and
I say hey I know where a lot of the
potholes are in life and maybe I can
tell you where they are and share my
life experiences ways so that you don't
have to step into those potholes and so
that's what I try to do is is to to
share like old guy told me one time
nothing in life is of any value unless
you can share it with other people and
so that is the essence of me at 80 years
old what is it that I have that I can
share with others and what can I give
away I I don't even know if I said this
to my wife yet so you you're gonna be
the beneficiary of a movement I now have
committed that I'm gonna try to give
away most of my personal belongings
again I'm gonna give away all my clothes
and my books I've go on I'm trying to
give away as much stuff as I can to
simplify my life I can only wear one
pair of shoes I can only wear one pair
of underwear I don't need all these
things and so I'm gonna rid myself of
all these these material things that I
thought were important that at 80 years
old the money's not that I learned
money's not that important collecting
things are not that important how you
dress all those things become what I
call surrender someone tells you what
time to get up in the morning what time
to go to bed what to eat what to dress
or how to act and so we end up being
prisoners of someone else's expectations
so I want to live than whatever time I
have left and I want to as Martin Luther
King said free at last free at last
thank God Almighty we are free at last I
just want to be free of all these these
these offenses that society has put up
around me and and I want to try to find
out where are my outer limits and once
you take down the fences you allow a
person to seek their outer limits and
that's what I'm trying to do at 80 years
old is to figure out where my outer
limits are and to keep reaching for well
coach
I hope to have many more conversations
with you so thank you so much sir thank
you and may you may you be around for at
least another 80 and what a gift of a
conversation thank you thank you I
appreciate you giving me the time and
for everybody listening for links to
everything we talked about certainly
where you can find coach raveling online
and learn what he's up to
in addition to the books that we
discussed and everything else you can
find all of that linked in the show
notes at tim dot blog forward slash
podcast what a ride and everybody out
there until next time thank you for
listening hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday that provides
a little morsel of fun before the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out
just go to 4-hour work week come that's
four hour work week calm all spelled out
and just drop in with your email and
you'll get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoyed
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books fresh books has become the go-to
cloud accounting software for literally
millions of small business owners who
found a faster more efficient and much
less stressful way to deal with their
numbers and ultimately this helps you to
focus on what you are best at it is used
by many of the fastest growing startups
I've invested in or advise and it's
equally used by many of the best
freelancers I work with on a daily or
weekly basis it is one of the easiest
ways to send invoices get paid to track
your time and track your clients if
you're self-employed and managing
business sometimes means wrestling with
spreadsheets crumpled receipts and other
scattered pieces fresh books can really
help fresh books allows you to do many
many different things very easily
preparing and sending a polished branded
invoice takes about 30 seconds you can
set yourself up to receive online
payments from your clients in about 2
clicks which on average will get you
paid twice as fast their new proposals
feature means you can include a project
summary and timeline as part of your
estimate there are many many other
things
tracking your time be quick proposals
that I mentioned formatting free
super-easy late payment reminders who
don't have to chase people automatic
expenses sharing files and messages with
your clients award-winning customer
service they are extremely responsive
the interface is super intuitive and
there's almost no learning curve so in
short it's easy it saves you time and
right now fresh books is offering an
unrestricted 30-day free trial for all
of my listeners to claim yours check it
out go to fresh ebooks.com forward slash
tim and enter tim ferriss in the how did
you hear about a section and that is
funky spell t IM fe r RI SS so again go
to fresh books comm forward slash tim
and enter tim ferriss and how did you
hear about us section check it out this
episode is brought to you by audible
which has the largest selection of
audiobooks on the planet I've used
audible for many years and I have
several audio books to recommend right
off the bat if you're looking for a new
one ready player one by Ernest Cline you
may have heard of it the town of Seneca
by Seneca if you want to hear my
favorite collection of letters of all
time as well as the graveyard book bye
Gaiman which is a fiction book I used to
reintroduce nonfiction purists to the
beauty and truth and enjoyment a fiction
graveyard book it is incredible and I
like the version that Neal reads himself
but the entire ensemble cast is also fun
audible members get a credit every month
good for any audiobook you the store
regardless of price and unused credits
roll over to the next month so if you
didn't like your audiobook no problem
you can exchange it no questions asked
plus your books are yours to keep with
audible you can go back and read listen
anytime even if you cancel your
membership and for some books again
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman
I've listened many many times you may
even just start over as soon as you
finish it the first time audible also
helps you to listen to more books by
letting you switch seamlessly between
devices picking up exactly where you
left off whether it's on your phone
through your car from a tablet or at
home on Amazon echo whatever you can get
through tons of books hands and eyes
free while doing almost anything so that
is part of the beauty of audio it is a
secondary activity when you are walking
the dog cooking whatever it might be
audible content includes an unmatched
selection of audiobooks original audio
shows news comedy and much more from
leading audio book publishers
broadcasters entertainers magazine and
newspaper publishers and business
information providers maybe that's what
I am a business information provider and
right now audible is offering listeners
of this podcast a free audio book with a
30-day trial memberships check it out go
to audible.com forward slash tim and
browse the unmatched selection of audio
programs download a title free and start
listening is super simple go to
audible.com forward slash tim or text
tim to 500 500 on your complete learn to
get started today check it out
you
you